Cleveland's police and crime
Commissioner very Coppinger has written
a letter to the Home Secretary Sajid
Javid outlining plans to give addicts
free heroin under a scheme to allow them
to inject the drug up to three times a
day the project costing twelve thousand
pounds a year per patient aims to save
money by improving health and cutting
crime seeking to cure addicts by giving
them access to medical treatment and
specialists the West MS at Midlands
Durham and even and Somerset police and
crime commissioners have backed the
initiative now whether or not you
believe that Boris Johnson actually
stopped icing sugar up his nose or care
if Rory Stewart admitted to smoking
opium in Iran or indeed whether you
think Michael Gove scam pain took a
nosedive after he admitted to taking
cocaine off his nose our hypocritical
approach to drugs is finally beginning
to change it's about time that we all
came down of the collective high caused
by our 1980s war on drugs hysteria and
accepted criminalizing drug users just
doesn't work so I find this a very very
interesting topic and for me it's not
necessarily about the drug it's it's not
hard versus soft it's not about you know
legal vessel evil it's about a person's
relationship with a drug so you know
many people will have taken drugs and
you know that's their choice it's
certainly not my choice it's not how I
live my life but for me it becomes a
problem when somebody is addicted to a
drug and that for me when it is where it
becomes a health issue and it's the
addiction which is causing the problems
in society and it is the addiction
around which there is a huge amount of
stigma and decriminalizing drugs is only
one part of sort of solving a problem in
addition to decriminalization you've got
to be able to have proper conversations
around problem drug use and addiction
and where we've gone in our society is
we've got so many charities that help
addicts and we seem to be pushing the
problem of addiction over to charities
as opposed to actually having proper
health based strategies around how do we
deal with problem drug users and when
you think of a heroin user for example
so much stigma around what a heroin user
is whether it's a smackhead or a druggie
or whatever it is and actually they are
just people like you and I who more
often than not had challenges in their
life haven't been able to cope with
those challenges used a drug as a safety
net and then found themselves in a
situation where they are now addicted
and cannot get off that chemical so
decriminalization want aspects but make
sure if you're going to do that you're
going to have these drug clinics or
whatever you want to call them in the
streets where people can inject safely
you've must then also have a joined a
perfects where you've got all of the
services psychotherapy and all the rest
of it to help people get off and stay
off drugs in the first place yeah Nick
did you realize they've never had a
single death in any of these centers
where they are implemented in York no I
didn't I find that very interesting yeah
and I'm going to deploy the old
politicians trick of asking questions
and answering them have we lost the war
against drugs yes do we need to try and
pioneer a new method yes we possibly do
my problem with this is the poor souls
who are addicted they have to show that
they are starting to wean themselves off
because there will be people list of
people watching this show right now
we've got elderly relatives the idea
12,000 pounds hold on 12,000 pounds a
year going to these people who are
terrible I know they're they have they
have they have to show that they are at
least trying to come up it cannot just
be and I just tell you that's less money
than it cost us at the moment because
they're just adjust the cost of one
share needle infecting one with HIV is
up to 80,000 roughly I mean jelly new
people watch in 2017 75 such cases have
hurt I'll tell you people watching this
would find it strange that that person
man or woman qualifies to 12 gram when
grande debt can't even get its gas bill
so I think one of the reasons that this
is such a good idea is is actually I
completely agree with you Michelle it's
that change of focus so you shift from
your approach to drugs being a war on
drugs which you're right we're losing so
it becomes you take it out of law and
order and into public health yeah
because what we need to do is focus on
harm reduction and that means looking at
addiction and and the model that people
always cite in these examples is in this
situation is Portugal because Portugal
did precisely that it
did the policy and it turned it into a
public health policy and so over the
past 15 years it's had since that's been
implemented it's had these amazing
results realized or drugs micronized or
drugs so it has gone from a hundred
thousand people who are addicted to
heroin down to twenty five thousand
people and it's also reduced the rate of
infection because obviously the risk of
HIV is higher for heroin users are often
sharing needles so creating that shift
in consciousness where you try and look
at harm reduction rather than crime and
punishment is what has what has led to
this transformation also drug fueled
crime just on the money-saving aspect
again dick when you're clocking when
you're basically addicted you need your
next hit and you're desperate and you
don't have a health facility to utilize
that's when people are robbing people
for or stealing bikes just for that
fifty quid so they can buy a small dose
and problem of course is the overdoses
occur in that way as well because it's
an infrequent usage with impure
substances and because the the purity of
it fluctuates you're injecting a
consistent amount but sometimes it's
ultra pure sometimes it's very weak and
you don't know what you're injecting and
you accidentally overdose yourself so
all of these are costs on the health
system whether it's because of the
overdoses or the crime cost and the
criminal justice system and what they
have found whenever they've trialed
these services open-ended budget can I
just keep getting twelve well what they
found where they have to so they
implement this in certain countries they
found that frequency of use does not
increase so I haven't looked to whether
it decreases but it doesn't increase
which is a year what you're saving money
yeah you know I don't really know
anything very much about this area and
I'm interested in listening to the
argument my contact to be honest is that
my mother and my aunt when they were
live lived together and we had to move
them from the place where they live
because dealers were operating outside
their front door no no they at that
point they're two 70 year old ladies
coming in there through the needles and
and this and that and the other so my
instinct is
actually I would stuff all of that and
that this this propositions quite
attractive the problem is I don't that
the place where it's been tried here in
Bristol
it doesn't appear particularly to have
worked very effectively and I think
there is a slight feeling of sticking
plaster over a massive ghastly
catastrophe with this sort of solution
we have the war on drugs doesn't seem to
work but that doesn't mean that we do
anything else that might look like it's
worked I I'm not sure that I think this
will solve the big problem we have AIDS
let's let's have a let's have a look at
what he he said he says the that's the
Cleveland police and crime Commissioner
very competent cop in J says the cohort
selected are those for whom all previous
treatment has failed they are the most
prolific offenders they lead chaotic
lifestyles in which virtually every
minutes focused on funding their next
hit and that's the [ __ ] thing else to
me mother if we can remove that
obsession we can then look to engage
other agencies including health and
housing to finally get these users off
the streets and back into society so but
the point you made it's interesting that
the Home Secretary was requested by the
Scottish representatives of the SNP in
Parliament because that's where some of
these trials are being rolled out to a
degree of success and he was asked
whether he could change the law to
facilitate the specific rooms where
people could go and inject their own
substances under supervision and he
refused citing exactly the reason Trevor
that you've decided but for the opposite
side he said he grew up on a street in
Bristol that was the drug-dealing Street
and he saw the effects and didn't like
it but actually the rebuttal to that is
what you said he would take the drug
dealers off the streets well see I'm not
even sure that but the problem is what I
think is my my uneasiness about this is
I think it underestimates
both the skill the determination and the
sheer ruthlessness of people in the
drugs trade they will breeze past this
and they will find other ways of hooking
people I mean yeah but this is the
argument for decriminalizing and pulling
the rug from their feet in terms of the
black market that's inflation yeah
that's it from a show that I'm into
I wanna crack jokes I've got a really
uncomfortable feeling in my tummy and I
feel like I need to respond because I
know people have died from heroin
overdoses I know when I was a teenager I
had never used heroin just for the
record but I was unfortunately exposed
to it a fair amount in my teenage years
and I know a people that used to use
heroin and I know people that were
desperate to get off it and I know one
particular gal and this is what's making
my my tummy go funny because when you
say about grandma's and granddad and
they think this these people that use
heroin they're not this started off the
same as you and I they're not bad people
they are people that have struggled in
life and we can argue wrongly have
turned to a drug that they're perhaps
and then they stuck they cannot get off
it and these rooms that you're talking
about they're not going to work on their
own you can't have a room to allow you
to inject and then arrest you in the
street for carrying when you leave
you've got to have a full 360 approach
where you're doing the whole thing to
support people to get off and stay off
crucially stay off those drugs here's
what the home office says we must
prevent drug use in our communities and
support people dependent on drugs
through a treatment and recovery heroin
assisted treatment is an option open to
local areas under the existing legal
framework and we support areas that
pursue this approach where the relevant
licenses are obtained from the home
office picking up on Travis Point majid
I guess it probably needs further trials
isn't it ninety new countries and Canada
and Australia are trying it and it's all
seemingly successful